I feel like Steve and I might not be
friends after this video that's because
you suck at arts and crafts and I'm
awesome I think I don't need the
instructions I could do this for days I
feel like a child but it's fun I'm
already like done you said this would
take 40 minutes I'm thinking 5 I don't
know what I'm doing at all no this is a
disaster ah actually I feel like my
girlfriend would enjoy it but we were
sitting here together doing it well
she's not I can't be hurt Steven Oh Oh
mine is clean - like sugar okay my was
like crap I have to say it turned out
really nice this reminds me of LeBron he
does this thing the power toss it looks
like what it is which is you rolled salt
onto a mason jar
Oh mason jar Lee I'm actually so excited
I've always loved hot glue guns oh
that's garbage it's like once I make one
mistake I'm like [ __ ] it I don't care
anymore but I do I want this to look
nice I feel like this is taking longer
than it should this is really [ __ ]
hard who invented this stupid [ __ ] I
feel like the world [ __ ] just Martha
Stewart right now how do you reload this
thing what is it with these things in
twine why do they always want to make it
very twine to stay suit look I can't
look right now it's too busy I screwed
it up but then I managed to get it back
on track Stephens is ugly we are doing a
3d snowflake together because Christmas
is all about getting along with each
other I don't have a good feeling about
this craft but I'm terrified yes I
caught the first pieces of paper wrong
disaster had to get new pieces of paper
shameful and half Matt show me the right
way to cut mm-hmm surprising all right
all right we can do this you did what I
think putting IKEA furniture together is
easier than that this could be in a
museum the shittiest saddest Museum I
don't understand how you can be bad at
cutting you know I understand how you
can be so mean to someone so [ __ ]
cute very mature here that looks like a
person more than a snowflake snowflake
dancer maybe you can do it in light fast
motion
he's available for polities there's just
one it turned out even better than we
expected and this is like Picasso you
know it's always fun to do crafts but
you forget how frustrating it is Kate
messed up a lot I think it's cheaper and
it means a lot more when you do it
Steven and I should do Pinterest crafts
every year because clearly it works out
great
you're welcome to Merida haha and God
bless us everyone
marry Chris berry Christmas thank you